clint barton is one of the original six
avengers and because of this hawkeye
show we get to share together all of who
clint barton is in a very exciting way
the ronin vigilante was spotted for
christmas i promise
hawkeye is compelling because there's a
sense of this ordinary guy is just
driven by this sense of duty more than
anything he doesn't have the protection
of superpowers and i find it interesting
that you get to join him where he
essentially found the piece that he's
always wanted but you know that there's
been this price has been paid
ow
clint has always been the human face on
the avengers he has all these things
about him that i think parallel a lot of
people's true life experiences and it's
amazing what happens when you let you
know actors like jeremy renner really
have the space to explore their
character
this is the first christmas we've had
together
in years i love you guys
jeremy is very much into the truth about
the character
having been clint barton for the last 10
years he knows this character inside out
it's been an exciting exhilarating sort
of ride and it's hard to quantify what
it's meant for me in my career
but when i think of the mcu and my
experiences playing this character it
becomes much more of a personal journey
and
i'm excited to see where it goes
you